va mourir Jo comment
la mère Addy Bund va
mourir le courant sombre coule des tourbillons qui s'estompent
se déplacent le long de la surface pendant un instant
silencieux
impermanent profondément significatif comme
si quelque chose juste sous la
surface laissait attendre un moment
Rich
sou attends D attends je ne le fais pas  on se soucie de ce qu'on fait
tant qu'on fait quelque chose assis
ici sans rien faire
j'ai vu quelque chose D de m'a dit de ne le
dire à
personne ce n'est pas à propos de Paul ce n'est pas une question d'
argent ce n'est pas à propos de Je ce n'est pas sur le point ce n'est
pas à propos de moi
c'est
CR  c'est ce que tu
veux